Okay so, classification learning. Before we get into the details of
that, I want to define a couple of terms. Because we're going to
be throwing these terms out all throughout the lessons. And I
want to make certain that we're all on the same page and we
mean the same thing. But we're returning to this again and
again and again. So, the first term I want to introduce is the
notion of instances. So, instances, or another way of thinking about them is
input. Those are vectors of valu, of attributes. That define
whatever your input space is. So they can be pictures,
and all the pixels that make up pictures like we've been
doing so far before. They can be credit score examples like
how much money I make, or how much money Michael makes.
>> [LAUGH]
How much money I wish I made, so on and so fourth. So
whatever your input value is, whatever it is you're using to describe the input,
whether it's pixels or its discrete values, those are
your instances, the set of things that you're looking
at. So you have instances, that's the set of
inputs that you have. And then what we're trying
to find is some kind of function And that
is the concept that we care about. And this
function actually maps inputs to outputs, so it takes
the instances, it maps them in this case to some
kind of output such as true or false. This is the,
the categories of things that we're worried about. And for most of
the conversation that we're going to be having, we're going to be thinking
about binary classification, just true and false. But the truth is, this
would work whether there were three outputs, as we did with
high school, college, or grad school, or whether there were 250 as
we were contemplating for ages. But the main thing here is the
concept, is the function that we care about that's going to map pictures,
for example, to true or false.
>> So okay, I get, I get the use of the word," instance", right?" Instance"
is just, like, a single thing that's out there. But I have an intuitive notion
of what a concept is. How does that relate to this more formal notion? Like,
can we connect this to, kind of, the intuitive notion of what a concept is?
>> I guess so. So a concept, I don't know. How
would you want to put that? So a concept is something That,
I mean were talking about is a notion of a
function, so what it means formally is that you have
some input, like a picture, and it immediately inputs maps
anything in that input space to some particular defined output
space, like true or false, or male or female, or
credit, credit worthy or not. Intuitively a concept is an
idea describes a set of things. OK, so we can
talk about maleness or femaleness. We can talk about short and
tall; we can talk about college students
and grad students. And so the concept is
the notion of what creditworthiness is, what
a male is, what a college student is.
>> Okay, I think I see that. So, so essentially if you want to think
of tallness, the concept of tallness, one way to define it is to say, Well in
general if you give me something I can tell you rather or not its [UNKNOWN]
so it's going to map those somethings to am I tall or not. True or false.
>> Right. Exactly and so
really when you think about any concept and we talk about
this in generally [UNKNOWN] is effectively a way of saying is
effectively a set of things. That are apart of that concept.
So, you can have a concept of a car and if I
gave you "cars" you would say these things are in it
and if I gave you "non-cars" you would say they are not.
And so a concept is, therefore by definition, a mapping between
objects in a world and membership in a set, which makes it
a function.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> Okay.